Our subject for this morning, I think
it's still morning, prophecy in your
face.
What did I say?
Thank you ladies for that beautiful
message.
I want to invite you to open your Bibles
to the book of John chapter 3.
We'll be reading John 3 verses 16
through 21.
John 3 beginning with verse 16.
For God so loved the world that he gave
his only begotten son
that whosoever believeth in him should
not perish but have everlasting life.
For God sent not his son into the world
to condemn the world but that the world
through him might be saved.
He that believeth on him is not
condemned but he that believeth not is
condemned already because he hath not
believed in the name of the only
begotten son of God.
And this is the condemnation
that light is come into the world and
men loved darkness rather than light
because their deeds were evil.
For everyone that doeth evil hateth the
light neither cometh to the light lest
his deeds should be reproved.
But he that doeth truth cometh to the
light that his deeds may be made
manifest that they are wrought in God.
May the Lord bless the reading of his
word.
The power of God is manifested in the
beating of the heart
in the action of the lungs
and in the living currents that
circulate through the thousand different
channels of the body.
We are indebted to him for every moment
of existence
and for all the comforts of life.
The powers and abilities that elevate
man above the lower creation are the
endowment of the creator.
He loads us with his benefits. We are
indebted to him for the food we eat the
water we drink, the clothes we wear, the
air we breathe.
Without his special providence, the air
would be filled with pestilence and
poison.
He is a bountiful benefactor and
preserver.
The sun which shines upon the earth and
glorifies all nature
the weird solemn radiance of the moon
the glories of the firmament spangled
with brilliant stars
the showers that refresh the land and
cause vegetation to flourish
the precious things of nature in all
their varied richness the lofty trees,
the shrubs and plants, the waving green,
the blue sky, the green earth, the
changes of day and night, the renewing
seasons all speak to man
of his creator's love. He has linked us
to himself by all these tokens in heaven
and in earth.
He watches over us with more tenderness
than does a mother over an afflicted
child.
Like as a father pitieth his children
so the Lord pity of them
that fear him.
Councils on stewardship page 17
paragraphs 1 to 4.
God is good.
And all the time
Psalm 100 verse 5, for the Lord is good.
Do you understand that?
When God blesses us
he's good.
When he punishes us
When he answers your prayer
he's good.
When he says no
When he sent the flood
he was good. When he burned up Sodom and
Gomorrah he was good.
God is always good. We need to
understand that thing about God. You
know the Bible says he that cometh to
him must believe that he is first.
He's good.
He's righteous.
He cannot do wrong.
Psalm 145 verse 17, the Lord is
righteous in all his ways
and holy in all his works. Let me say it
again. God cannot do anything wrong.
So for those of us who think God is
arbitrary and he did not do what I told
him to do, God cannot do anything wrong.
That's why Jesus said, they hated me
without a cause.
No one has a just cause to be angry with
God.
Not Jonah
angry because God didn't burn up
Nineveh, whomever, no one,
am I clear, has any just reason to be
angry with God.
I love God. How many of you love God?
Can I see your hand?
He's a nice person.
He really is.
God doesn't get the credit he deserves.
Someone wrote me
last yesterday
Friday, no, Thursday, well
couple days ago.
When I pray, I don't know what to say.
And I wrote back and said
next time you pray, don't ask God for
anything except forgiveness of sins.
Just spend time thanking him. You'll
find a lot to say.
Thank him you can see.
Thank him you can hear.
Thank him you're not dumb.
Thank him you can put one foot ahead of
the other.
Thank him you're sane. You're not in a
some institution for the mentally
unbalanced. Thank him you're not in some
rehabilitation program for the fifth
time trying to break some addiction.
Thank him you're not homeless. Thank him
you're not starving.
Just thank him and don't ask him for
anything except forgiveness of sin.
Thank God. God is a nice person.
All those who agree say amen.
Let me say what I love to say. In my
life all my blessings have come from
God.
All my problems I have brought on
myself.
All my hardships
I authored by my stupid decisions my
stubbornness and my refusal to follow
thus saith the Lord. God has never done
anything wrong
in my life.
Nothing. And I thank him publicly for
being that kind of God.
Who is with us? You're not a Seventh-day
Adventist. We have not yet met you. May
I see your hand?
We have three lovely ladies last night.
All right, you're back again in the same
seat.
Is it Clara?
Carla.
I was in the neighborhood but wrong
street. God bless you for your
persistence
in spending your time where the truth of
God is spoken. Say amen for the lovely
sister to my left. Anybody else?
You were here last night. You come back.
You're not an Adventist.
Anyone?
Where?
Hi. Oh, yeah, give us your name again.
Beverly. God bless you, Beverly. Thank
you again for coming to be with us. We
are delighted you've come. We really
are. We may not look like it but we are.
So God bless you. God bless you,
Beverly. All right.
Our subject for this morning, I think
it's still morning, prophecy in your
face.
What did I say?
How many of you have Bibles? Can I see
them?
Ah, I'm impressed.
No, I really am.
I really am. I was at a church a few
years ago and they were singing
the song some hymn using screens and God
thank God for technology. Then the
the
electronic system malfunctioned
and they stopped singing.
And I said, this is no way to worship
God.
The church stopped singing
because the screen malfunctioned.
You know, I always said we need
old-fashioned sermons, old-fashioned
ways, old-fashioned preachers,
old-fashioned mothers and fathers.
In my day
that's before any of you were born.
This can't malfunction.
A hymn book cannot malfunction.
And if you drop it, it doesn't break.
Are you following me?
Anyway, I'm just an old-fashioned
preacher. I like to see hymn books in
people's hands and Bibles. God bless all
screens but uh sometimes they
malfunction. All right, are you okay?
You slept well?
You thank God for life?
You did.
Did you thank God for life this morning?
Who didn't?
Well, then that's a good to thank him
and repent?
All right, you know, let me let me tell
you something which you know.
Tell me if I'm right. Last night all
over the world people went to sleep,
right or wrong?
Expecting to wake up in this morning, am
I right?
Many were found dead, am I right? Yes.
In hospitals,
private homes, on the streets, on the
battlefield,
dead.
God has allowed us to live.
Never take life for granted.
Never.
All right, prophecy in your face. If
you're using a phone, please make sure
it does not ring. I did not hear one
ring last night. Thank you very much for
cooperating. A favor number two, while
I'm speaking, pray for me and say,
"Lord, put your words in that man's
mouth."
Jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9, then the
Lord put forth his hand and touched my
mouth. And the Lord said unto me,
"Behold, I have put my words in thy
mouth."
And favor number three, think. Isaiah
1:18, "Come now, let us reason together,
saith
the Lord."
As you listen to the message, as you
worship the God of heaven and earth,
before whom angels veil their faces,
I want you to pretend you're sitting in
a courtroom.
In the presence of a visible earthly
judge.
Now, I don't need to tell you there's
some things you dare not do
in the presence of an earthly judge. You
just will not do it. People seem to know
automatically how to behave when they
sit in a courtroom and that robed person
sits in that chair.
Well, God is the God of all the earth.
He's the judge of the universe.
Keep in mind, you are in the presence of
God.
You don't need to see him.
We are in the presence of the holy God.
If you agree, say amen with me.
Let us conduct ourselves accordingly.
Let's pray.
Father in heaven,
Job said
in chapter 40 verse 4,
"Behold, I am vile.
What shall I answer thee?
I will lay my hand upon my mouth."
Isaiah said in chapter 6 verse 5,
"Woe is me!
For I'm undone
because I am a man of unclean lips."
Peter said in Luke 5 verse 8,
"Depart from me, for I am a sinful man,
O Lord."
Paul said in 1 Timothy 1:15,
"This is a faithful saying and worthy of
all acceptation,
that Christ Jesus came into the world to
save sinners, of whom I am chief."
If Job,
Isaiah,
Peter,
and Paul
can speak that way of themselves,
what do I say about me, Father,
as I stand before you?
Surely, Lord, I must be that dog that
eat the crumbs from the children's
table.
But you're merciful God.
You make your sun to rise on the evil
and on the good,
on the just and on the unjust.
Since I did not seek this request,
Father, but you sent it,
please feel some burden to help me.
Tell me what to say,
when to say it,
how to say it, Father,
and fill me with the very humility of
Christ that when the spirit speaks, I
will listen.
I ask you to bless your sons and your
daughters gathered in your presence.
Cleanse our hearts from sin, Father,
because nothing
confuses truth more than sin.
I humble myself before you.
If we're online, bless the online
audience.
Bless every family,
every individual, a special blessing on
our visitors, and a double blessing on
the children.
Wherever your people are worshipping
you, Father, right now,
bless them, dear God, I pray.
And through the agency of your spirit,
unite our hearts as one.
Thanks for the honor of speaking for
you.
Bless this country.
Bless the leaders, dear God. Bless every
country represented by this
congregation.
Remind the leaders somehow
that righteousness exalteth a nation.
Hear this humble prayer, Father.
We offer it in Jesus' name. Let God's
people say, "Amen and amen."
Prophecy
in your face.
As Adventists,
we're very familiar with the prophetic
timeline,
which is extracted from careful study
of the word of God.
We are familiar with what we call last
day events.
We have a book called Last Day. By the
way, if you've never read it, please
read it. It is a compilation of the
writings of Ellen White. Read it, your
eyes will be opened, your faith
strengthened.
When we think of last day events,
we think of
Tell me.
National Sunday law, yes, that's an
event.
Give me another.
The time of trouble, yes, that's an
event. Give me another.
Say it again.
The second coming, that's an event. Give
me another.
The the the what? The shaking, that's an
event.
Give me another one.
The close of probation, that's an event.
No, no, no, let's be honest. When we
think of last day events,
what comes to mind?
Uh I Okay, okay, okay, okay, all right,
okay. Let's not be the Tower of Babel.
Uh what what are you saying?
The loud cry.
That's an event and a message.
Anything else?
Say it again.
All right, that's an event. I hope
you're there. If you don't If God allow
doesn't allow you to live until he
comes. Mhm. We are familiar with events.
We know, according to the Bible, there's
something called the end of time and the
time of the end. Am I right?
This side.
When did the time of the end begin? This
side.
Too slow, that side.
1798.
In mercy, I come back to that side. When
did the time of the end begin?
The end of time, sorry. When did the end
of time begin?
This side.
When does the end When did the end of
time begin?
October 22, 1844. What do you understand
by the end of time and the time of the
end? The time of the end, 1798, when
certain events will take place, the
Bible the books of Daniel Revelation
will be more clearly understood, the
gospel will go to the world, all the
Bible uh
um associations came into existence. The
end of time is the end of prophetic
time,
which began in October 22, 1844. And so,
if there's an Adventist giving you uh
dates for future events beyond that, uh
bless that person and just pay as little
attention as you possibly can.
Because we're told clearly from Bible
study in L Y, there are no other events
to be identified by dates beyond October
22, 1844.
And that includes the 2520.
All right.
Let's look at some things
that will happen.
We hear the mark of the beast, am I
right?
Yes.
Does anyone have the mark of the beast
now, yes or no?
No, why?
Because the Sunday law has not yet been
passed. There is not yet a universal law
requiring the observance of Sunday. When
that comes into existence, then men and
women are confronted with a choice of
God's law over man's law. Those who
choose the law of men will then have
taken on the mark of the beast.
We hear the time the little time of
trouble,
the little time of trouble, great time
of trouble, all these things we hear
about, the outpouring of the latter
rain, and so many of them are events.
Now, we think of organizations
associated with the last days.
Name one organization. It should be the
first you name.
The papacy.
That's an organization, yes, a system.
Another organization.
The United States, yes. God bless United
States, yes. Name another organization.
The what?
Okay, okay, okay, yeah, okay, the false
prophet, all right. Name another.
Those secret organizations, we don't
know what they're doing. Name one.
The who?
The Illuminati, okay, yeah, we love that
word, the Illuminati. We don't know who
they are, but we love the word. Anyone
else?
Well, whatever. You can name United
Nations, the Council on Foreign
Relations. We have all these cons-
conspiracy theories, but we we know
these organizations and we know these
events and this is end time events, the
closing of probation. End time events,
the beginning of Christ's ministry in
the most holy place. End time events,
the passing of the Sunday law. End time
events, the close of probation. End time
events.
Nation shall rise up against nation and
kingdom against kingdom. There shall be
famines and pestilences in diverse
places. And so we see the tsunami of
204, 206. That's an end time event. Then
an earthquake over here, that's an end
time event. And so we look at these
events and these organizations and these
people. And so when Kennedy became
president before any of you were born,
we thought the world would come to an
end.
Not because he was a Catholic president.
When 9/11 took place, we thought the end
would come. When the Berlin Wall fell in
1989, people came out with some
prophetic explanation as to why it fell.
When the logo of the church was changed,
someone had some reason as to why it was
of prophetic significance. We are
focused on events and organizations and
that's that's fine. Don't misunderstand
me.
But I want us to take a personal look at
prophecy.
Because we're not saved
organizationally.
We're saved personally.
That amen was weak.
I said we're saved individually.
You don't take your family before the
bar of God.
You go by yourself.
And you cannot tell God the preacher
preached a bad sermon, that's why you
did not understand forgiveness.
You're not 2 years old.
Salvation is personal.
Destruction is personal.
Let us go
to 1 Timothy chapter 4.
What's our subject?
Prophecy face to face.
1 Timothy 4.
We'll read from verse 1.
Do you have that?
I can still hear the music of the pages
turning.
But you still need to hurry up.
1 Timothy 4.
We're reading from verse 1.
Let me pray before we read. Father, I
don't want to speak long without seeking
extra and additional power. Literally
possess my speaking apparatus, I pray,
in Jesus' name. Amen.
Read with me if you have my version. Now
the Spirit speaketh expressly that in
the latter times some shall depart from
the faith. Stop. Well, let's continue
that verse. Giving heed to seducing
spirits and doctrines of devils. Stop.
Is that a prophetic statement? Yes.
Look at it again. Now the Spirit, who is
that?
The Holy Spirit speaketh, what's the
next word?
Give me some synonyms for expressly.
Directly.
Distinctly.
Plainly. The Spirit, so no one needs to
be confused.
There is no greater teacher of truth
than the Holy Spirit.
John 16:13, Jesus said, "How be it, when
he, the Spirit of truth, is come, he
will guide you into all truth."
Now the Spirit speaketh expressly that
in the latter times, give me another
expression for the latter times.
Last days.
This is prophecy.
Some
shall depart from the faith.
Do you know people who've left the
church?
When the verse says some shall depart
from the faith, this verse is not
targeting the world. The world does not
depart from the faith.
I'm talking to myself.
Nobody's listening.
This is talking about the church.
And not the Catholic church.
For that day shall not come except they
come a falling away first and that man
of sin be revealed. The Spirit speaketh
expressly that in the latter times some
shall depart from the faith. Do you know
people who've left the church?
Yes.
At every level.
There was a man, I won't call his name,
he used to be in charge of church
planting for the North American
Division.
Church planting.
And left the church.
Even administrators
who've left the church.
Pastors by the hundreds who've left the
church.
In the latter times some shall depart
from the faith. Now,
there are people who say the church is
Babylon.
So they have to leave to start a pure
church somewhere in a in a valley
somewhere.
I want you to observe.
Here's God's church.
And here's the direction in which
apostasy flows.
Are you following me?
Some shall do what?
Depart from the church.
You're not with me.
Let the Bible help you. Go to John 15.
John 15.
It is
uh
5 to 12, I think.
I'll let you out as soon as I can.
John 15, let's read from verse 1.
You have it?
I am the true vine and my father is the
husbandman.
What's the vine?
Based on all I've said, what's the vine?
Let's read on.
I am the Jesus is the head of what?
The church.
The body of the church is the
Come on. The body of Christ.
What's the vine?
The church.
Of which Christ
is the head.
Sometimes I can be a little strict.
If that's okay with you, say amen.
Good. All right. I am the true vine and
my father is the husbandman. What does
the husbandman do?
Make sure the vine is in good shape. Are
you with me? Every branch in me that
beareth not fruit,
he taketh away. Now, in which direction
does that branch go?
Out.
He does not take away the vine.
So when you leave the church saying the
church is Babylon,
the Bible doesn't teach God takes away
the church. He takes away the branch
that is false.
So when you leave the church, you're
headed in the wrong direction.
And every branch in me that beareth
fruit, he purges it that it may stay in
me, I'm adding that, and bear more
fruit.
When you leave the church,
you declare yourself to be a branch that
the husbandman has removed.
So when you start an organization with
fellow believers who have left the
church,
what are you starting?
Let's go back to 1 Timothy chapter 4
from verse 1.
When you find it, say amen.
Now the Spirit speaketh expressly
that in the latter times some shall
depart from the faith. Read with me now.
Giving heed to what? Seducing spirits
and doctrines of devils. Stop.
What is a seducing spirit?
Mhm?
Listen to this verse. Just listen.
And when the woman saw that the tree was
good for food
and that it was pleasant to the eyes and
a tree to be desired to make one wise,
she took of the fruit thereof and did
eat.
What did she do when she did that?
She sinned. You're too slow. She sinned.
Now,
and gave also unto her husband with her.
What was she functioning as?
A seducing spirit.
Representing whom?
Satan.
When Eve encouraged her husband to sin,
she functioned as an agent of Satan.
When you tell people Ellen White was not
a scholar, you don't need to read her
works, you are seducing spirit.
Giving heed to seducing spirits and
doctrines of devils. Now, here is the
seducing spirit. Here's the person
giving heed. The seducing spirit is
exercising a negative influence on that
person.
Without being too harsh.
We talked about a man this morning who
led many ministers out of the church.
He was
a seducing spirit.
I've never met him, but I heard he was
the nicest person you could meet.
And the nicer you are, the more
difficult it is to see your error.
Because how can someone so nice
be so wrong?
Giving heed to seducing spirits and
doctrines of devils.
What is a doctrine of the devil?
Any teaching contrary to truth
is a doctrine of the devil.
That goes all the way back to the Garden
of Eden. And God said, "In the day thou
eatest thereof, come on, thou shalt
surely die." Genesis 2:17, Genesis 3:4,
"And the serpent said unto the woman, ye
shall not surely die." That is a
doctrine of the devil. And it has
persisted. It is the foundation of
spiritualism and the occult world.
Now, let me ask you as we continue
prophecy face to face. Are you a
seducing spirit?
What is your influence on people
spiritually?
Don't answer me.
Are your relatives closer to Christ
because of you?
Are there some people who will have
nothing to do with God because of you?
Or me?
Seducing spirits, whether deliberately
or by default of having a
weak relationship with our God.
That's prophecy.
In the last days
some will influence others to leave the
church and ignore the truth of God.
Let's forget the Pope.
Let's forget the Illuminati. What is
your influence on people?
Let's stay personal.
Prophecy in your face and mind.
Stay in Timothy, this time chapter 2.
Not chapter 2, sorry. Second Timothy, I
should say.
By the way, there I've noticed there's a
new way of referring to the books, and
I'm an old fashion. It is not two
Timothy.
Are you with me? I hear people on 3 ABM,
and I just want to jump into the screen
and say, "Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
There's a way to call the book."
It is not one Timothy. It is first
Timothy, and it is second Timothy.
Now, you don't need that to go to
heaven, but you need to know so you can
be sophisticated. Come on, say amen. All
right, second Timothy chapter 3, let's
read from verse 1.
Do you have it? You don't have to go
that far. You should have it by now.
Let's pray again. Father, continue to be
with me, Lord. Suppress my carnal
nature. Let your spirit have his
absolute way with me. Bless your sons
and daughters with comprehension. In
Jesus' name we pray. Amen.
Verse 1, 2 Timothy 3.
This know also that in the what?
In the what?
What is that?
Now.
We are a people of prophecy. Is this a
prophetic statement we're about to read?
Yes.
This is as prophetic as Daniel 8:14.
This know also that in the last days
perilous times shall come. Now, you will
observe, let's read the perilous times.
For men, come on, shall be lovers of
their own selves, covetous, boasters,
proud, blasphemers, disobedient to
parents, unthankful, unholy, without
natural affection, trucebreakers, false
accusers, incontinent, fierce, despisers
of those that are good, traitors, heady,
high-minded. Keep reading.
Lovers of pleasure more than lovers of
God. Keep reading. Having a form of
godliness, but denying the power
thereof. From such turn away. Stop. Now,
observe microscopically.
Are earthquakes mentioned?
Floods?
Wars?
As in Matthew 24? No.
The emphasis is on what?
This has nothing to do with the beast.
At a personal level. Are you following
me? It is easy to look at the beast
through a telescope.
That's the beast. Oh, yeah. Okay. I see
the horns.
So, that's the Illuminati.
You know, you you go out in the field,
you have binoculars, so you you sharpen
your view by Bible study, and you have
it theoretical in your head.
Ah, that's the Pope. Okay.
There goes uh whomever.
Uh-huh.
Ah. Yeah, that's the close of probation
coming. I see it.
I see it. Let me become a vegetarian
quickly. I see it. I see it.
Oh, here comes the time of Jacob's I see
it. I see it.
And so, we're very distant.
We're almost like prophetic tourists. We
tour these sites and these events, and
we have we're tour guides, and we tell
that's the close of probation, that's
that. And but this is saying, "What
about you?"
You.
This know also that in the last days
perilous times. What are the perilous
times? What's the first one? Men shall
be lovers of their own selves. That's
why the church doesn't have enough money
for the gospel. We spend it on us.
We line up outside the Apple store
for the latest model.
And we use God's money.
Black Friday
and Black Monday and Pink Tuesday.
We're all in line
to get the bargains. For what?
Men
shall be lovers
of their own selves.
Question for you. Don't answer me.
Does that apply to you?
Is the Pope responsible for the fact you
love yourself?
Are you blaming the Illuminati?
Where is prophecy now?
Face to face.
Lovers of their own selves, covetous,
boasters, proud, blasphemers.
Disobedient to parents. Let me talk to
the young people.
Do you obey your parents?
That smile looks like guilt.
The Bible says disobedience to parents
will be a sign of the end time, which
means it will be worse in the end than
it was in past centuries.
Why would it be a sign if it wasn't?
There will be rebellion not only against
your biological parents, but biblically,
the older men of the church and the
older women are your mothers and
fathers.
The Bible says it. 1 Timothy 5:1-2.
Ellen White says that.
Honor thy father and thy mother includes
the older people of the church.
If you're in the church as a genuine
member, when you marry a lady in the
church, you've married your sister.
Nobody's listening to me.
I'm talking to myself.
Young people, do you obey your parents?
That's my question.
Rebellious children
are a sign of the end time.
Yeah, you you
When I
I look at children today and I look at
children in my day. You know, my day.
The days of Columbus when he sailed the
ocean blue.
And I asked myself, "What happened?"
When a teacher walked into the
classroom, you stood up.
You didn't talk.
You sat when he said or she said, "Sit."
A teacher spoke to you,
you just kept quiet and you obeyed.
If your parents found out the teacher
had to talk to you.
Today, teachers are running from cover
for cover from bullets
and knives
and physical violence.
Today, youth have no respect at all
for seniors.
A sign Now, I'm speaking to my young
brothers and sisters. Is the Bible
describing you?
Don't tell me you're 12. Jesus was 12.
The Bible says in Luke 2:50 and 51, he
went down and was subject to his
parents. Here is God obeying his
parents.
Disobedient to parents.
Unthankful.
Unholy. Question for you. How thankful
are you? How thankful am I for the daily
moment by moment blessings of God?
Do this for me. Do that.
Just that. Just do that.
Now, do that.
Do you know how many processes are
required to do that?
Because this is muscular contraction.
Do you know how many steps, micro steps
are required to do that?
Do you know who arranges all of that and
keeps it working?
There's a camera on me. I don't want to
go far, but I step back, step back, step
back.
Do you know how many muscles involved
for me to do that?
To keep my balance, to not fall, to have
a sense of where I am in space?
In him we live. Come on.
And move. Come on. And have our being.
Unthankful.
Unholy.
unholy people
Ellen White writes, "The new birth is a
rare experience in this age of the
world.
That is why there are so many
perplexities in the churches."
unholy people
but decent
They talk about their righteousness, but
they don't live it.
They're law-abiding, but unsaved.
Perfect in the eyes of the world
but unrighteous, unholy, leading the
churches.
The Bible says in the last days
the church will have unholy. This is not
about the world.
Next verse, "without natural affection,
no love for the brethren"
trucebreakers. You make a pledge to
support the church, you don't follow up.
false accusers
incontinent, no control
fierce, ooh
There are some church members will fight
you at the drop of a hat
or a hairpin.
I mean literally, physically get up in
your face
with a glass of soy milk in his hand.
There are members who have attacked
pastors.
fights on the church board
fierce members of the church
will put you in your place in a minute
to let you know who's who.
A new pastor comes and someone has let
the new pastor know who wields the
greatest influence.
So, watch your step, pastor.
fierce
mean
but nicely dressed
without natural affection,
trucebreakers, false accusers,
incontinent, fierce, "despisers of those
that are good"
Christ suffered that all his life.
You see, righteousness provokes a
response.
When you decide to live an upright life
in the eyes of God by his power, your
greatest opposition will come from the
church.
I have a friend in a certain country.
Well, yeah,
certain country, I won't name it.
She chose to homeschool her two
children. She was disfellowshipped.
along with other families who chose to
homeschool "despisers of those that are
good"
I have known churches where medical
missionaries were thrown out
for preaching the health message
thrown out and forbidden to return
"despisers of those that are good"
traitors
And the greatest treachery is against
God and the truth he has imparted and
entrusted to this church. traitors
heady, not thinking, just responding
no thought no deliberation, just react
traitors, heady, high-minded
"I am all there is to be."
As we say, "I am all that."
with a bag of chips with some dip Are
you with me?
I'm all that, high-minded.
Here comes this one that applies to so
many of us. Finish the verse 4:4 for me.
"lovers of pleasure"
more than lovers of God
You arrange
a banquet, everyone comes with furs and
dresses that are kept in
climate-controlled cli- uh closets.
And they all come to this banquet to the
church.
You arrange a Bible study, nobody comes.
You arrange a basketball game on
Saturday night, everybody comes.
You arrange a Bible study, nobody comes.
"lovers of pleasure" more than lovers of
God You know what Jesus said? "This
people honoreth me with"
their lips. Finish the verse. "but their
heart is"
Titus 1:15-16,
"They profess that they know God, but in
works they deny him."
"lovers of pleasure"
more than lovers of God
consumed by what the Seattle Seahawks do
and no interest in the Autumn Council or
the Spring Council. Are you with me?
"lovers of pleasure"
Somebody said last night that was I
don't know if it was Brother Wilson.
um
We just or Brother Norm, we can't wait
for the sun to set
to get the scores
the playoff results.
This is college football now. I'm in in
Ann Arbor where I live, we have the
largest football stadium in the country
where the Michigan Wolverines play. On
Saturdays,
and they're playing at home, you traffic
is is hellish.
People fly in from all over the country
to spend a weekend, you know, alumni to
see their teams play, rent the hotels,
and people rent their backyards to to
park, and you park for $20 for 5
minutes, you know, it's that sort of
thing.
"lovers of pleasure"
And then we go from Saturday to Sunday,
the end of the the NFL. You go to Green
Bay, and they're all wrapped up in coats
because it's an outdoor stadium. It's
10° below.
And the stadium is packed. Are you with
me?
to watch 22 men fall down and get up
And the church now is empty.
But if you say, "How many love Jesus?"
everybody loves Jesus.
"lovers of pleasure"
more than lovers of God
Verse 5, read it loud for me.
"Having a form of godliness" "but
denying the power thereof. Finish it.
From such"
Now, this is this is say serious.
There are some people in the church from
whom you should avoid.
Let me say it again
differently.
There are some people in the church
whose influence will harm you
spiritually.
Never feel obligated to be close to
everyone in the church.
What we just read describes church
members.
That's prophecy.
face to face
"Having a form of godliness"
"but denying the power thereof"
"from such"
"turn away"
I have no children, but if I had
There are children in churches I've
visited I would want not want my
children to mingle with.
plain This is not an superior attitude.
This is just facing reality. I have seen
children in churches, if I had children,
I would not let my children mingle with
them.
"from such"
"turn away"
They'll say from such scorn.
minimize limit your exposure
Great Controversy, page 409, paragraph
1, the third time we're hearing that
that quotation "The scripture which
above all other had been both the
foundation and the central pillar of the
Advent faith was the declaration under
2,300
days, then shall the sanctuary be
cleansed." This makes us a prophetic
people, a people familiar with prophetic
events, and we understood that, and I
said that clearly at the beginning of my
presentation, but I want you from this
day forward to move your emphasis from
prophetic events to your prophetic
condition.
Let me
briefly take the burden off the
Illuminati
and the papacy
and the false prophet.
Where is Christ now?
Doing what?
For whom?
for us Give me another word for us.
the church
Does Christ forgive sins not confessed?
It is not the world that has Christ in
the most holy place, not yet coming
back.
Because they have nothing to
send up.
It is we
who will not stop sinning.
You see, this temple has to be made
clean before that one is clean.
Is this mic working?
It is.
Did you hear what I said?
This temple. Are we a temple, YES OR NO?
YES. Does it need to be cleansed? Yes.
THE CLEANSING HAS TO FINISH HERE BEFORE
it finishes up there.
That's not the world we're talking
about. The church.
Christ has not yet come back because of
us.
Not the Not their world. Not the Pope,
the Illuminati, whomever. I'm not
blessing them. I'm simply being honest.
We are the problem.
Because we won't stop sinning.
Are you following me? We will not stop
sinning, so we keep sending sins up and
Christ has to stay to take care of them.
When the fountain of sin is cut off
here,
Christ can stop his work up there and
come, no matter what the Illuminati
does.
Again, I'm not supporting the
Illuminati. Don't misunderstand me.
What's our subject? Prophecy
face-to-face.
Listen to the Bible.
And this gospel of the kingdom shall be
preached in all the world for a witness
unto all nations, then shall the end
come. Who does the preaching? The
church. Not the Illuminati.
In other words, God isn't waiting
for a specific schedule of events for
the Illuminati to fulfill or the papacy
or whomever. He's waiting on the church.
Christ subject lessons page 69 paragraph
one, Christ is waiting with longing
desire for the manifestation of himself
in his
people. When the character of Christ hmm
shall be perfectly reproduced where?
What will happen? Then he will come to
claim us as his own. What does the
Illuminati have to do with that?
I'm going to close in a minute, but let
me
apprise you of a condition that was
brought on by sin, which is blame
somebody else.
Yes. So, when God spoke to Adam, Adam
said, "The woman you gave me." When God
spoke to the woman, "The serpent."
We genetically blame. It's an
instinctive response that can only be
controlled by the spirit of Christ. Are
you with me? We
Even when we're wrong, we blame others.
And so, we blame the Illuminati and we
blame the Muslims for being hard to win
and the Hindus for being hard to win and
the Buddhists are hard to win. They're
not hard to win.
We are hard to win.
You didn't follow me.
Who gave God most problems in the in the
Bible?
The Israelites. Not the Canaanites.
Not the Babylonians.
The Israelites.
The very people he could not destroy.
He destroyed the others.
Did he destroy the Egyptians in the Red
Sea?
Yes.
In Judges 4, when the Midianites Was it
the Midianites? The Canaanites came and
Barak went with a Deborah. Did he
destroy the entire army? Yes.
Did an angel destroy 185,000
Assyrian soldiers under the generalship
of Sennacherib? Yes.
But where did God destroy all the
Israelites? Nowhere. He couldn't.
Let's forget ancient Israel.
Let's look at modern Israel.
Last night I told you we have a message
that will prepare Christ to come back.
Not prepare Christ, prepare us to
receive Christ.
When I say us, I mean the whole world.
Because your preparation can either be a
righteous one or an unrighteous one. Let
me explain that. There are two harvests
in Revelation 14.
Both are right.
Are you with me? Both are right. The
harvest of the saved, the harvest of the
lost. Both must come to the place of
righteousness before Christ comes. The
message we have does that.
I thank God for prophecy.
I thank him for Revelation 13, which
identifies a Daniel 7,
the little horn, the man of sin,
the papal system.
I thank for Revelation 13:11-18 that
identifies the false prophet.
I thank for Revelation 12 that
identifies the dragon.
I thank for Revelation 14:6-12
that identifies the remnant church
Revelation 12:17, Revelation 18:1-4,5.
But let me tell you something.
God is waiting on us.
And I want you to maybe perhaps as a
recommendation, take a little time and
leave the papacy alone for a while.
Give the beast a break.
Because the beast is not the superstar
of Revelation, it's Jesus Christ. Are
you with me? We study Revelation as
though the beast is the superstar. It is
the victorious Jesus Christ is the
superstar of Revelation and Daniel.
Give them a break for a little while
and focus on 2 Timothy 3:1-5.
Now, if you have the King James, read it
with me, then I'll close the service
with an appeal. 2 Timothy 3, let's read
from verse 1. Let me pray first. Father,
as I come to the close, I hope I've
spoken clearly. Let the spirit close it
off with divine revelation, I pray, in
Jesus' name. Amen. Do you have 2 Timothy
3?
Read with me from verse 1 of chapter 3.
Now, the spirit speaketh this know also
that in the last days perilous times
shall come. What those are these What
days are those? These days. Now, read
with me, "For men shall be lovers of
their own self." Come on. "Covetous,
boasters, proud, blasphemers,
disobedient to parents, unthankful,
unholy, without natural affection,
trucebreakers, false accusers,
incontinent, fierce." Come on.
"Despisers of those that are good,
traitors, heady, high-minded, lovers of
pleasure more than lovers of God, having
a form of godliness, but denying the
power thereof. From such turn away."
Take some time and let that be your
prophetic focus.
And give the beast a break.
Take some time.
And deal with prophecy face-to-face.
How many of you are grateful for 2
Timothy 3:1-5? Can I see your hand?
Stand up with me.
It was written for you and me.
I am going to read that passage again.
This is my appeal.
As I read the passage,
if anyone of those things applies to
you,
come.
I will pray.
Did I say that clearly?
I will read 2 Timothy 3:1-5.
If anything on that list applies to you
personally, come.
This know also that in the last days
perilous times shall come.
For men shall be lovers of their own
selves,
covetous,
boasters,
proud,
blasphemers,
disobedient to parents,
incontinent,
fierce,
trucebreakers, false accusers.
I don't need to finish the list.
Maybe I should add having a form of
godliness,
but denying the power.
If any of those things applies to you,
come.
The Bible says the heart is deceitful
above all things.
Above all things.
The most deceitful thing in the universe
is this.
Above all things.
And to my chagrin and possible
embarrassment,
the first thing the heart deceives is
the person who has it.
Not someone else.
It deceives you first
into thinking that you're okay.
Heads bowed.
Eyes closed.
Dear God,
thank you for your fatherly rebuke
in 2 Timothy 3:1-5.
Father, we know
as a church, we've studied the beast,
the false prophet,
the man of sin, the papacy. We've
studied the end of time, the close of
probation, the time of Jacob's trouble,
Sunday law. We've studied all these
things, dear God, and we must continue
to study them.
But Father, too often we function as
prophetic tourists just looking at these
sites from a distance.
Today,
you have come right into our faces.
Some of us are lovers of ourselves,
covetous, proud, boasters,
disobedient to parents, unthankful,
unholy.
All these things, dear God, and more.
Some apply to us.
And Father,
we've come to say forgive us, dear God.
Forgive us for thinking it is some
organization that has delayed your
coming. We are the guilty culprits.
As verily as the Jews were guilty of not
warning the world for this of the first
coming of Christ.
Only a few wise men from the east and
the shepherds found out after Jesus was
born.
Father in heaven,
your servant says, "We have given given
more knowledge and information than any
other generation on the earth.
With that in mind, we need to remember
to whom much is given,
much is required.
And so Father, as we bow as a church at
this altar,
let us look at you individually.
Forgive us. Forgive me
if any of those things applies to me or
to my brothers and sisters. Forgive us,
God.
Especially lovers of ourselves.
Remove that, Father, and all the other
problems vanish. No wonder it is listed
first. Satan loved himself.
Jesus loved us.
Dear God,
I ask you again,
forgive us, Father.
Now do for us what David asked you to do
for him in Psalm 119 verse 18, "Open
thou mine eyes
that I may behold wondrous things out of
thy law, that I may see how your word is
speaking to me at a personal level."
Father,
bless every man,
every woman.
Help us to set our affections on things
above
because Jesus said, "Where your treasure
is,
there will your heart be also."
And if the most important things to us
are things on this earth, we will have
no interest in heaven.
Transform us, dear God.
Transform
Father,
which is changing a creature into
another species.
It's not making a dirty pig a clean pig,
Father. Conversion makes a dirty pig an
eagle.
Do this for us, dear God. Forgive us for
letting you down. Forgive us, Father.
Now grant us a measure of your spirit,
dear God. As we partake in the potluck,
let us do so to your glory. Whether
therefore you eat or drink, to your
glory because that verse has no
exceptions.
Thank you for loving us.
Thank you for your patience. Ah, Father,
your so long suffering we cannot
understand how you can endure our
weaknesses so long. But we thank you for
doing it. But we don't want to push your
patience. Let this be the beginning of a
different period in our lives, I pray.
And Father, when you come,
save us, dear God.
Save us abundantly into your kingdom.
Until then, may our lives lead others to
Christ.
I pray from my heart, dear God, in the
name of Jesus Christ and for his sake.
Let God's forgiven people say, "Amen and
amen." God bless you. You may return to
your seats. We'll have our closing song.
Let's pray.
Holy Father,
we thank you for your word
and for the good instruction of your
spirit.
In the name of Jesus Christ, dear God,
as we leave,
let us remember the righteous man
described in Psalm 1.
In his law doth he meditate day and
night.
Let us reflect, dear God. Let us not
engage in this compartmentalizing of our
lives where we open the Sabbath morning
drawer. When the sermon is over, we
close it. We open the potluck drawer.
Let's keep the sermon drawer open, dear
God.
That we reflect on your word, minimize
idle chatter. This is the Sabbath, not
speaking your own words.
We are peculiar people.
Bless us, God.
May our behavior put a smile on your
face today.
In Jesus' name we pray. Amen.